hey you know good morning listen Labor
Day weekend is supposed to be a big busy
weekend for Florida beaches all along
the East Coast but right now hurricane
durian is definitely impacting that and
a lot of these businesses are following
the warnings right now take a look right
behind me this place actually said last
night we are open just a few hours later
they are now saying we are closed and
that is because here at Cocoa Beach they
are one of the first to order a
mandatory evacuation and that goes into
effect a Sunday morning at 8 a.m.
there's only three today
time is running out to prepare for
hurricane durian and so were the
supplies I'm already good and I have
plywood up I'm ready to go
Karen Mota ferry started her day early
to purchase batteries and other supplies
she says she was here for hurricane
Matthew but is not planning to stick
around for durian you're not taking any
chances nope I am not the uncertainty of
where hurricane durian will land has
people all along Florida's east coast
hunkering down the time to act is now
you do have some time but that time is
running out across the state residents
are facing long lines at gas stations
and fuel shortages this is C Port
Canaveral the fuel that supplies most of
Central Florida has to come through here
and there is a huge supply 38 million
gallons ready to go but when hurricane
durian hits Florida there is no doubt
this place will have to shut down and
that supply will be cut off David Smith
is the seaports general manager we stay
open until emergency services are
closing the causeway and say it's no
longer safe
that's when we'll send our team home
up to 400 trucks come through this tank
farm transporting fuel to nearby
airports and gas stations the plan is to
shut down Port Canaveral by Saturday
night small boats will be out of the
water and cruise liners will be turned
away biggest concern about this storm is
the uncertainty of where it's going in
the intensity of which it's coming in
families are waiting hours for sandbags
and food and water are flying off the
shelves state officials are also
checking on nursing homes to make sure
they have generators after 12 people
died in 2017 when hurricane
knocked out the power at nursing homes
local hospitals actually started their
evacuations yesterday they're taking
patients inland to some of those
hospitals are on the other side of the
causeway we also know that shelters will
be opening up sometime tomorrow for
people who are leaving but need a safe
place to ride out this storm Michele
best advice get out of the I get out